president Trump continued to downplay
the reports describing his conversation
with the Ukrainian president in July as
absolutely perfect we had a great
conversation conversation I had was
largely congratulatory was largely
corruption all of the corruptions taking
place was largely the fact that we don't
want our people like Vice President
Biden is done creating to the corruption
already in the Ukraine the unverified
and vague accusation against Joe Biden
was echoed by the Secretary of State if
there was election interference that
took place by the vice president I think
the American people deserve to know we
know there was interference in the 2016
election and if it's the case that there
was something going on with the
president's family that caused a
conflict of interest and Vice President
Biden behaved in a way that was
inconsistent with the way leaders ought
to operate I think the American people
deserve to know that Joe Biden says it
was the Obama administration as a whole
along with the EU that called for the
firing of the then Ukrainian prosecutor
back in 2016 and the matter had nothing
to do with his son and president Trump's
critics insists they will not be
distracted from finding out why the
White House Counsel will not allow the
release to a congressional committee of
the whistleblowers complaint this tweet
from House Intelligence Committee
Chairman Adam Schiff if there's nothing
wrong with Trump's core with ukrainian
President as he claims why won't he
release the transcript he asks if
there's nothing to implicate Trump in
the whistleblower complaint
why won't they release it to Congress
clearly they are afraid we must see both
and even some Republicans are expressing
concern if the president asked or
pressured Ukraine's president to
investigate his political rival either
directly or through his personal
attorney tweets senator Mitt Romney it
would be troubling in the extreme
critical for the facts to come out the
Acting Director of National Intelligence
has been
subpoenaed to appear before the House
Intelligence Committee on Thursday the
question he's certain to be asked why is
he refusing to allow congressional
oversight of a whistleblowers complaint
that's been described as credible and of
an urgent nature Mike Hanna al Jazeera
Washington